foreign
folks welcome to the August security
talks today we're going to learn how we
can detect threats in our Cloud
environments with security Command
Center my name is Tim peacock I'm the
senior product manager for threat
detection here at Google Cloud
celebrating four years on this group and
here at Google when I'm not detecting
threats as part of security Command
Center you can also find me co-hosting
the cloud security podcast by Google
today's talk is going to be a look at
some of the new and improved threat
detection capabilities inside of
security Command Center premium security
Command Center is a four-part service we
think of it as providing first a pillar
a visibility to security teams they say
you can't manage what you can't measure
you certainly can't secure what you
can't see on top of that visibility
across your cloud of State we build risk
management in the form of both
misconfiguration of cloud resource
detection as well as vulnerability
detection with a lot more coming soon in
that area on the threat detection side
of the house which will be the focus of
today's talk we've got you know a lot of
investment to detect when bad guys do
bad stuff despite all of the Investments
we make on the left-hand side of the
house preventing bad things finally we
know that it's no good securing your
environment if you can't prove to your
audit and compliance teams that you've
done so so all of the misconfiguration
work inside of SEC is pivoted against
leading compliance standards and it's
easy to grab that data and Export it out
before I dive into the demo I want to
give you a quick overview about how we
think about threat detection in Cloud if
you've read our blog post on threat
detection in Cloud Parts one and two
some of this may seem familiar but what
I want to run you through as a security
professional if you haven't read that is
there's really good news and bad news
when it comes to threat detection in
Cloud the good news is that your needs
as a security professional come into
Cloud they don't change you still need
to keep your data confidential you still
need to run software you trust and you
still need to keep your systems
available
when it comes to miter attack your miter
attack tactics don't change but the
tactics and procedures that adversaries
use to achieve those goals change
dramatically and we did ourselves a bit
of a disservice three four five years
ago back when we went to in-person
events and we all had hats and pins and
buttons and shirts and tote bags that
said things like oh the cloud is just
someone else's computer the truth is the
cloud is a lot more than someone else's
computer there's a lot more to it you
think about something like a cloud
function where is this somebody else's
computer in a cloud function now I think
of the cloud as having this kind of six
layer model and like all models it's a
lie but like many models I I hope it's
useful uh when I think about defending
the cloud I think things really start
all the way on the left hand side here
with protecting our identities in our
identity policy configuration those
identities speak to a common API which
in Google Cloud give us unique
opportunities for instrumentation that
common API enables and manages a set of
managed Services things like bigquery
where we we can understand those API
requests on a very deep level being the
service provider there is still a
network and there are still
opportunities for network-based threat
detection so what you know about
network-based threat detection doesn't
change necessarily but how you achieve
those goals of network-based threat
detection instrumentation may change
security dramatically in cloud and with
uh you know Global shift towards
encrypted traffic your opportunities for
deep inspection might be going away in
the near future we do still have compute
in Cloud it's not just someone else's
computer we still have persistent
kernels and we'll talk about some of the
really exciting work we're doing through
virtual machine threat detection to
detect threats and compute later on in
this talk finally on top of compute we
have kubernetes both as an orchestration
layer and as a runtime environment past
security sessions have looked in a deep
way at the work we're doing with
continuing threat detection so we're not
going to talk a lot about that today but
I do encourage you to go check out our
past sessions talking about kubernetes
to understand what we're doing for
threat detection there finally before we
dive into the content I want to touch on
what I call the Anna Karenina principle
of clouds now I was listeners a
political science major in college so I
get to say weird things like that and
what I mean by that is Tolstoy opens
that book by saying all happy families
are alike every unhappy family is
different in its own way
every cloud is different in its own way
when it comes to detecting threats and
even misconfigurations in a particular
Cloud you want as a security
professional the highest Fidelity threat
detection or misconfiguration infection
for that cloud and its particularities
what you know about an identity model on
ad does not translate one-to-one with an
identity model on gcp
similarly what you know about detecting
data exfiltration out of AWS does not
translate one-to-one with detecting data
infiltration out of gcp as an industry
we have a never-ending drive towards
standardizing our response practices
standardizing how our teams operate
but that doesn't mean we should have a
never-ending drive towards standardizing
how we detect the things that feed into
our team's triage queue so as we go
through the Demos in a second you'll see
a couple of examples where we're doing
very particularized to gcp things and I
encourage you as Security Professionals
to think about where does
standardization need to happen in your
stack and where do you want to lean into
the most relevant tool for the job at
hand so with that let's turn it over to
our demo we're gonna walk through a
pretty typical example of how an
organization can suffer a leak of
credentials have those credentials get
used how the adversary can achieve some
of their goals and how Google Cloud
helps automatically detect and security
teams respond to those issues so with
that here we are home page of security
Command Center this is the view for your
organization when you first open
security command center after you've
onboarded had it detect a few things
here we are in a pretty typical looking
organization with a few findings of
different types we're going to
immediately pick into this account has
leaked credentials finding this finding
is a partnership with GitHub and like I
said at the start one of the most common
ways organizations get into trouble with
the security of their environment is the
leak of an access credential in this
case GitHub actually let us know in
pretty close to real time that a service
account key was checked into a public
GitHub repository now we can pick in to
the details and we can see a few things
here in this Json tab that let us
understand exactly what's going on and
now we can scroll down and scroll down
and if you find a few things that are
going to really help an engineer or a
security operations person understand
what's going on in particular uh the
project identifier to understand where
in the organization this leak occurred
what the name of the compromised account
is in this case test leaked essay
and a little bit more detail about
what's going on as well as the
particular key identifier so that the
user can understand exactly which key
for that account leaked as well as the
URL where that key was posted in this
case into a project owned by Google
Cloud platform
now let's imagine the case where an
adversary gets access to that key before
anybody else does and they log in from a
new location I'm using as an example
today for that detection of persistence
new geography actually a finding that
was generated about my account a couple
weeks ago when I was traveling in the UK
you can see that in this case our caller
ipg or region code is us but in other
cases I was calling in from other places
we can again pick into the Json see a
little bit more detail about what's
going on here in this case the typical
geolocations are GB and now this
actually detected not only that I had
been over in the UK but that I came back
to the US and then did something else so
this is a pretty cool finding showing uh
the ability of event threat detection to
trace our activity back and forth across
the pond uh shows that I was able to get
over and visit a few customers now uh
one of the things that we obser serve
adversaries do when they compromise an
account particularly a service account
is look up what the capabilities are on
that service account now
you can imagine an adversary who gets
their hands on one of these credentials
starts to say to themselves oh what can
my new toy do and one of the common ways
to understand that is to look up the IM
policy for that service account as that
service account now it's quite normal
for human users to say oh what am I
capable of do I have the permissions I
need to do my job today
on the other hand the typical life cycle
of a service count
is that it's created for a particular
purpose put into use to do that purpose
and the service count never has reason
to introspect its own capabilities we do
occasionally see this happen with
terraform jobs and the team has done
quite a bit of work to take out false
positives related to terraform jobs but
in this case what we see is actually an
adversary looking up the IM policy of
that service account now this is pretty
typical adversarial Behavior
but say that these findings are not
enough for a security engineer at your
company to be convinced that something
is going on with that service count we
can look at yet another detection of
unusual activity on that service account
in this case uh we have a persistence
new API method detection what this looks
for this is actually a service within
security Command Center that uses what
we call uueba user entity behavioral
analytics one of those acronyms only
Gartner could love that looks to profile
the set of behavior observed for a
service account and now a typical
service account life cycle is to do what
you're going to do within your first say
seven days of service account existence
if a service count starts to do new
things after those seven days is usually
a sign that something has gone wrong
without service account in this case we
see that this thing has started to touch
this vulnerability detection settings uh
well after it was established we can
again pick in the Json get a few more
details out of the finding and see some
interesting things so in this case I was
actually editing uh some things within
the security Center settings so that's
that's pretty unusual that a service
count would start touching security
Center settings after uh it hadn't
previously done so in its existence
again an example finding from inside my
engineering org but let's say that this
adversary
has now gotten access like we said in
the start to that credential discovers
the capabilities of that credential and
discovers that that credential not only
has access to data but has access to
update a VPC service control now VPC
service controls are powerful gcp
platform capabilities to limit or
constrain your environment these are
very useful for Central Cloud Center of
Excellence teams Central Security teams
posture teams getting set up in Google
cloud and saying Thou shalt not do X and
in this case we have a service perimeter
that prevents data from leaving an
environment now if I'm an adversary
who's hoping to cause data to leave an
environment that would be kind of
inconvenient but fortunately for our
example bad guy here he's been able to
modify that VPC service control and now
we detect that as a miter tactic
defensivision and we can pick into the
details to understand exactly what was
modified in this case and so here we've
got the service perimeter and it was
modified to no longer protect a
particular asset and so this is a really
great uh look at how event threat
detection security Command Center really
able to get into the detail of how
Google Cloud works and how the different
capabilities of Google Cloud relate to
each other we always say that each cloud
is different from the others and when it
comes to defending a particular Cloud we
know that security teams want
consistency and want centralization but
security teams have already achieved
consistency and centralization in their
alert triage cues through their Sims or
or other tooling
we believe the most important thing for
security teams is to have the
capabilities that best understand the
particularities of a particular cloud
and as you can see with this particular
finding type this is a case where ETD
and security Command Center really
understand the particulars of Google
cloud and can detect when a VPC service
control is weakened to have a protection
removed from that organization so now
imagine that that protection was removed
what is the adversary able to do in this
case the adversary was able to move data
out of that environment they took it
from this test bucket and X they took it
from this project this Cloud SQL
experiments project and exfiltrated it
to this test bucket now in this case
we've detected that data has moved from
a cloud SQL service out to a bucket now
in the past you've seen demos from
ETD and security Command Center premium
detecting data exfiltration out of
bigquery here we are publicly talking
about for the first time moving data out
of cloud SQL we know that users bring a
lot of important data to Google cloud
and that users trust Google Cloud to
protect that data it's not always the
case that users configure things to be
fully locked down and when things are
not fully locked down or when a defense
was weakened by an adversary who got
access to a highly privileged account
we're really happy to be able to help
users detect in very close to real time
when that data moves out of their
environment
now let's say this adversary is not
satisfied merely moving data around and
weakening controls let's say they want
to go a step further and find another
way to monetize in that cloud
environment well by far the most common
way we see advertise uh adversaries
monetizing a cloud environment is with
the use of crypto mining now crypto
mining is a super straightforward thing
that adversaries can do in a scripted
and automated Manner and because it's so
easily done so quickly through
automation this is really one of the
things that we see is the proverbial
Canary in the coal mine for discovering
that an environment is not fully secure
and so to that end we've actually
released multiple capabilities inside of
security Command Center premium that
look for this type of behavior one of
those capabilities relies on our ability
to understand flow logs and Cloud SQL
Cloud DNS logs in close to real time in
this case a malware bad domain finding
that we generated the other day this one
was actually looking for uh our test
domain our test indicator and we can
scroll into the details and see our
indicator domain as our etdm malware
trigger.goog we have a test domain
registered it's that users of the
service can verify and to end that
things are working but in the
adversarial case we would see access out
to something like a mining pool domain
and so that's a great way of detecting
from the network layer that a bad guy
has started running some crypto mining
now let's say they are perhaps
stealthier than that and they're using a
custom domain that's one of the reasons
we released an additional capability
through a service that we're calling
virtual machine threat detection
virtual machine threat detection as
previously mentioned in the introduction
uses our possession of having the
integrated n10 Computing stack and our
ability to instrument the hypervisor to
detect based on memory analysis the
execution of a crypto Miner in close to
real time in this case we're using our
ability to run Yara rules against the
contents of memory we've got multiple Ur
rules triggering on this process of LOL
funny name in this case the adversary
has clearly chosen the opportunity to
manipulate the binary that they were
running we weren't just looking for
binary names we were looking inside the
process to look for the kinds of
routines that are involved in
cryptocurrency mining so not only are we
able to detect at the network layer when
traffic is going out to a crypto mining
domain we're also able to based on
memory introspection enabled through the
hypervisor detect the proof of work
routines that crypto miners use to make
their money so having detected first the
compromise of the account out second
having detected the adversary's efforts
to weaken controls and move data on the
environment third detected their
attempts to monetize the environment
through crypto mining we're left with
the adversary establishing their
persistence in the environment and how
they achieve that and so looking for
that in Cloud takes a lot of forms and
those forms are not necessarily the
forms we expect to see on-prem
establishing persistence in an instance
for example in the cloud may be less
valuable in an ephemeral environment
when we think about our traditional CIA
Triad we can contrast it with the die
Triad distributed immutable ephemeral
establishing persistence in an ephemeral
instance is not really persistence at
all there are other things in the cloud
that are more persistent though things
like an IM policy and so one of the ways
that we see adversaries establishing
persistence in cloud is by granting
themselves privileged roles in an
environment in this case this is a
finding type that we've seen before with
event threat detection security Command
Center it actually takes us all the way
back to our launch of the service many
years ago when we granted an audience
member uh live in the room editor on a
project in this case our end-to-end
testing was doing the same thing and we
were detecting it in very close to real
time but let's say how else might
somebody establish instance well I said
that instances are ephemeral but the
ways that they spin up and spin down
give us access to things like
SSH Keys across an environment and now
because things are managed from the
orchestration layer from the control
plane we can add uh you know SSH Keys
through the API in this case the
adversary has added an SSH key which
will be good for them across the
instances in the fleet and we were able
to detect that as well so what you saw
today were a number of different finding
types all generated inside of security
Command Center all generated in close to
real time powered by our unique
understanding of logs our uniquely good
understanding of Google cloud and are
uniquely powerful instrumentation
through the cloud hypervisor
well listeners thanks for sticking with
me through the demo I hope this was an
engaging and interesting look at the
ways that security Command Center
premium can help detect some of the ways
that adversaries first get access to
environments second attempt tax filtrate
data third use and abuse your resources
to achieve crypto Mining and fourth
establish persistence in your
environment throughout we focused on how
SCC premium is really focused on the
particularities of gcp itself and how we
use our position as the Google cloud
provider to give you the highest quality
threat detection for your environment
you can learn more about security
Command Center premium by checking out
our documentation page as well as our
product page and of course on the topic
of threat detection in Cloud you can
check out Parts one and two of our
threat detection in Cloud blog post that
Anton Chewbacca and I did you can listen
to the podcast that Anton and I release
on threat detection among many other
topics every Monday cloud.withgoogle.com
Cloud security slash podcast and of
course thank you for joining us for this
month's security talks really appreciate
your time today folks
foreign